foreign
ask me anything AMA derived from
questions that you all have sent in
um either via the John delaney.com ask
or on the internets on social so Kelly
who's asking the questions today
I am you yeah good Jenna makes me
uncomfortable
not really that's not nice you asked
questions the other day actually I'm not
gonna lie she did a great job of course
she said no mean things to me and my
headphone Yeah well yeah see I'm still
working on it yeah you kept them all in
your in your heart in my head that was
fantastic I loved it it made me happy
all right so let's do this let's make
internet uh magic all right the first
question can a marriage work without
intimacy
no but I'm gonna caveat
um I think we
oh
so most people say sex
people in polite company especially
people in faith context often don't say
the word sex they say the word intimacy
or people who are trying to be proper
say intimacy so if we're using the word
intimacy to mean sexual intercourse yes
you can have a great and wonderful
marriage without sexual intercourse on
the regular particularly as you get
older as you age Etc
um the key here is it's it's something
that has to be navigated and discussed
and negotiated together it can't be one
person deciding this is the way this is
going to be and the other person's got
to live with it
um but I take a much broader view of
intimacy intimacy is a connection at the
soul level at the intention level in at
the every minute of my day I'm thinking
of ways I can meet my partner's needs
and they're trying to meet mine intimacy
is about doing the things that I know
help you have a better life and in turn
you're doing the things that help me
have a better life
and so intimacy is reciprocal and it is
connectedness and is together
um and so no I don't think you can have
a marriage without that without a shared
connectivity but yes
as you get older there's medical issues
as your sexual interest like actual like
doing it doing it wanes and other things
are more important like I just want to
sit here on the front porch and hold
your hand and like that can be deeply
intimate moments the key again is that
they're discussed is that is that fair
yeah because like you I think it's more
than I think the question is asked well
I'm asking it so I know what it is
um it's not just sex it's yeah it's
beyond just sex it's because intimacy
intimacy is more than that we've talked
about that there's more than just that
yeah all right the second one how do you
choose your tattoos
oh man so
usually I go with somebody and we take
seven or eight shots and I'm just
kidding we don't it all
um usually it's a couple of things one
um
like I've got tattoos down my ribs of my
children and the kids that we lost uh
the names of the children we lost
um at pregnancy and so sometimes they're
deeply meaningful the tattoos down my
back are from uh childhood stuff and
when I was trying to be a uh opposed or
want to be Fighter
um the ones down my arm are usually a
collection of things that are meaningful
to me and or
um kind of dealer's choice and so I
think I've talked about it here
I was try I travel a lot and so I just
decided I was gonna start getting new
tattoos in every city and so sometimes
man there were some pretty sketchy
things but usually is something that
means something important to me
all right how do you choose yours
just let's that's coming up another
question oh is it
sweet how do we let go of blame
um
blame is good for for honestly
evaluating how I ended up in a certain
situation
um somebody shoved me now I'm in the
middle of the road
that's helpful info
but it doesn't get me out of the middle
of the road
and so
I get over blame
honestly because it has absolutely no
help it's of no help to me and going
where I go next unless
um I know I'm not gonna go back on that
side of the road because that guy just
pushed me in the road right so it might
give me some direction here
um but it's not going to help me make my
next steps and so I I just think blaming
is a complete and utter waste of my time
um it just has no value what about you
you love blame and like it makes you
feel it makes your heart feel good no I
don't y'all seriously
[Laughter]
um
I have this need in like a you should
take
like you should be responsible for the
things you did
probably more to other people than I am
for myself which is not good but so I I
tend to hold on to it
um inside sometimes more than I should
so it's a Justice thing yeah
like you're wrong and so I'm gonna hold
on to this gotcha because clearly that's
a good thing to do sometimes I'm bad
about that whole you know it's like
taking poison and then hoping the other
person dies right that's something I
work on but it's not an easy thing
um to let go of blame blames helpful for
me in reflection yeah it's like what is
it righteous
yeah I feel like I'm holding on to this
because it makes you holier than now
it's a little bit of like of that if I'm
being real honest yeah I get that it's
like I exercise and that suddenly makes
it okay that I eat my body weight and
gar yeah I get it um so I I just tend to
think that blame
um
is a waste of my time and so I want to
pull that straight that that string all
the way
so let's say I was sexually abused as a
kid
and I have real challenges uh making
close connected relationships as an
adult
or let's suggest that um I was
physically abused as a kid and so when
somebody's angry or somebody wants to
have a strong disagreement with me on
the basis of my ideals or my ideas like
at work or in a marriage I instantly
hide I I run
those things in my childhood happened no
question about that and my body
naturally created defense mechanisms so
that those things would be less likely
to happen in the future no question
about that
but for me to continue as an adult to
blame what happened then
for the things I need to do to be well
and whole and treat people with dignity
respect in my in my life as an adult
it does me no good it I can't bring them
from the past to to make right my my
present it just doesn't know how it
works and so I just tend to on the whole
blame's a waste of my time I'd rather be
about what comes next how do I get to
the next place how do I
participate in healing how do I get a
new group of people to walk alongside me
nice all right
um top favorite three top three favorite
books on parenting and relationships
you say it one more time
top three favorite books on parenting
and then top three favorite books on
relationships oh geez uh uh
um that's easily easily the most common
question I get is questions about hey
what books what books what books what
books
um I almost thought about getting a
master's degree in library science just
because of how many how often I get that
um I think my number one parenting book
of all time is is hold on to your kids
by Gabor mate and Gordon Newfield hold
on to your kids
um an absolute absolute absolute
Masterpiece everything Kapoor mate
writes is a masterpiece that guy is just
uh like an international treasure he's
from Canada otherwise I'd call him a
National Treasure um there's another
book out that I haven't read this may be
an honest I haven't read it
um it's called baby Bomb
um by Cara hop Hopi Hoppe I think
um and she has another author Stan
something
um I've had it recommended a bunch I've
got it on my shelf I haven't read it but
I think it'd be worth picking up just
from the people who have recommended it
to me I highly trust
um I don't know that I have a third
probably scattered by Gabor mate it's a
book about ADHD
um but it has a broader picture about
raising kids and stress and maternal
stress and paternal stress and so that's
a phenomenal book as it as it comes to
relationships
um the new rules of marriage by Terence
real is extra ordinary
um
Come As You Are by Emily nagoski the
book on sex it's less about it's more
about a relationship between a woman and
her body but I think the men that have
read it have find extraordinary value in
it as well and I think it's a great book
that couples can read together and I um
Lori gottlieb's
is it maybe you should talk to somebody
is that right yeah
um that's a an extraordinary book as
well
um anything by
um Esther perel What About You Kelly do
you have a parenting book that means
something to you or relationship book
besides the karma sutra
parenting wise um
as a parent of a of a boy one of the
best ones we ever read was
um
David Denton who is a uh sorry David
Thomas he's a counselor local counselor
here at Daystar same place Golf
Works and he wrote a book called
um wild wild things and it is the it has
been the most referenced book in our
house for raising boys and it um does a
really good job of putting
like two to four here's who they are
four to eight here's who they are and it
talks about here's who they are
physically here's where they are
emotionally here's what they need from
Mom here's what they need from dad
here's what they need from outside
sources here's what they need
spiritually you know and then like to
the point where the point now where it's
like Mom you're not as big a part of the
picture now and that's really sucks but
so you treat me yes
well there you go
um but so here's what they need from you
and here's what they need and if if
there's not a dad in the picture if
there's not a mom in the picture it's
like a handbook that's cool and it has
been amazing how closely as I've looked
at that and then watched our son he
it's been a great one and then
relationships not my favorite book
overall you mentioned it the other day
but I think it's worth it is the five
love languages
only because my husband and I are
extremely different people
and so I I finally read that when
understanding that well maybe what I'm
doing is not
is isn't working he doesn't understand
that that's my way that I show I care
gotcha and so that did a good job of the
whole idea of it like you have to learn
your partner and learn what works for
them because I can buy him gifts all day
long but if to him that doesn't mean
anything it's useless yes and so I I
agree with you there that book gives a
great it's a great conversation starter
I think
um I I personally don't think there's
just five love languages but
um I do think they that they that
provides a great basis for a place to
start and you just said it perfectly
most of us go through our lives trying
to help other people and our hearts are
good especially those that we love the
most
but we help them in ways we want to be
helped not in ways that they're actually
Desiring to be helped right and then we
end up pushing them into the margins or
hurting them in an attempt to try to
love them right and they don't see it
they're like well gosh they must not
love me or like me or because if they
did they'd mow the lawn and we're over
here you know buying expensive gifts or
whatever so you just it's just about
getting on the same page and love it
yeah I love it um all right so those are
the great those are books there hang
with us we'll be right back with this uh
400th episode Ama